france 24 est le monde à vos
machines ministre
iman france 24 sur le front diplomatique
la russie est très isolé il ya vote les
nations unies à l'assemblée générale
seuls
quatre pays se sont joints à la russie
pour une ex voté contre une résolution
qui demandait elle a aussi annoncé ces
médias trop en fond d'opérations
militaires
l'otan est plus unie qu'elle ne l'a
jamais été depuis la chute de l'empiré
soviétique donc c'est un fiasco
diplomatique pour la russie n'est ce pas
vous savez c'est à vous de juger moi je
ne peux pas juger des décisions de notre
pays nous pensons que nos décisions sont
justes encore une fois c'est très
mauvais que les civils pour monter
jusqu'aux mais nous pensons pas au
fiasco diplomatique
je pense aux talents diplomatiques de
l'obs et lantus et tué des milliers de
civils
sont morts aux alentours de 15h jouit
l'un des civils sont morts dans le dos
face personne à l'occident aucun média
occidentaux
la catho pris la peine d'aller dans le
dos de base pour venir pour voir comment
les civils
un qui ont été
définis compte des terroristes comment
ils vivent comment j'y suis et suit une
des tirs
quotidiens
les écoles sont faux objets les tirs il
y à des actes terroristes sont membres
là bas dit
aussi
approché sélective assis à vous écouter
uniquement l'occident
les silences à 80 du non respect des
accords 2010 à retenir non seulement
kiev nous il ne mettait pas en oeuvre à
ces accords de minsk animé y autorise
continuez c'est leur acte militaire et
bien si vous pensez que tout cela c'est
ce serait entré en droit diplomatique
c'est à vous de juger
vous pensez que la russie a commencé à
défendre ses propres intérêts du club
vous avez dit que le temps est
maintenant très soudée comme jamais est
bien le temps à chercher parce que les
moyens la raison d'être sa raison d'être
qui a disparu depuis les événements de
l'afghanistan le temps à tous que kitty
le l'afghanistan est sûre ça use
maintenant à trouver un bon moyen de
rallier autour de soi ses alliés eh bien
monsieur macron en parler de
l'autonomie stratégique
et bien personne n'a surtout pas les
états unis permis permettront aux
autonomistes raté constrastée
ce qui concerne
les mathématiques que vous avez et les
chiffres que vous avez évoquées nous
savons
bien
moyen ou nos partenaires occidentaux
tiennent à c
résultat il est au 110 ha à tout le
monde
quel devrait être le résultat des votes
est super ils rappellent
sans rougir
kiosque des comptes bancaires à à
l'occident utile pour faire avec ses
comptes bancaires et je le sais parce
que j'ai des connaissances 1 à
l'occident et on me dit
pardon mois mais il est question de ma
prospérité de mon bien-être et je vais
voter dans ce sens là oui voilà c'est
comme ça que
je triomphe diplomatiques occidentaux
sont assurés je vous envie tout de même
à accous sujet les silly stuff nous
officiers
du ministère
pouvoir juste lire les commentaires de
la journaliste française et qui a vu ce
qui se passe dans le donbass non nous
ressentons pas cette
que nous sommes sonne sur la chaîne
internationale